joe biden i'm a democratic candidate for
the united states senate
can i get another
i was a democratic caucus caucus
no you hadn't you're a lion dogfish pony
shoulder senators who built their
reputations
and career on the segregation you also
work with them
to oppose busing that's not true
if i were serving in the united states
senate 40 years ago
when joe biden was serving there we
would have been on opposite sides
i was joking that was a joke okay
subject for today
that's a good one like radio you guys
probably are fans cubic junior right we
have the hodge twins
in the studio with us uh conservative
twins on youtube and then hodge twins on
facebook how you guys doing
we are doing amazing yeah now you just
saw yourself on the monitor yeah
okay oprah 2.0 she's always watching
herself on the monitor
she's always interviewing a guest tyler
perry riveting
uh quarterback garrett is here audio
wade is here my good morning lawyer bill
richmond hello
how are you sir i'm so glad to be
sitting in gerald's seat really are you
ready take it over rape is going to be
the topic of discussion oh
and i realized i was sitting there
watching it going wait wait a second
hold on a second
the joe biden by the way let me be
really clear allegedly
joe biden bill clinton and then michelle
obama who
really praised harvey weinstein like win
like this is only possible
because of harvey weinstein michelle
obama woman she really was she went all
in on the harvey weinstein thing
supporting him
she was basically acting like those uh
people from smallville in the sex cult
who were recruiting yeah
yeah she's like everybody hated you a
little bit but no the democratic
convention it could just
it's just the casting convention yeah
the creep shield
it's just one big couch so uh the
question
for you today i guess question of the
day is um
it's all allegedly okay everything is a
legend right half asian lawyer is
looking easy
there's smoke there's fire it's all no
no no sometimes it's just electrical
you never know it's just communications
sometimes it's just cake
on the oven just a smoke bomb sometimes
you just put the oven on self-clean
right yeah yeah i don't know yeah
um and uh it's all allegedly
but since we're opining who do you think
did it do you think bill clinton you
think he's guilty do you think that uh
joe biden is he
just really an enthusiastic sniffer um
did michelle obama who has the access to
the fbi dod all of the intel
throughout the criminal world had no
idea that harvey weinstein was stripping
every single uh
woman and uh girl who he was casting i
don't know i mean i don't know how she
lost it
yeah and it was an open secret so i mean
yeah i mean when seth macfarlane is
joking about it michelle
i had no idea aren't you the first lady
shouldn't you know
first um that's what it means of course
also in other news no one else no one
else agreed with me on this we're going
to be taking your chat
uh i should say a little later on please
do subscribe to crowder bits that's
another channel on youtube since
we don't know if monetization is going
to last you a long time and uh
we always talk about the the apple
podcast and spotify but uh
please do consider drawing oh shoot oh
no i got water all over my mouse pad
i'm not gonna replace it i've ruined
everything when you drink coffee does
your piece smell like honey nut cheerios
is that just me when i drink two they're
only two this smells different
there are only two things that make my
urine and it's asparagus we all know
that
okay don't get off your high horse and
your tower
asparagus we all know but coffee it does
but it doesn't smell like coffee it
smells like honey nut cheerios yeah i i
again i've noticed a difference but i
haven't made the connection to the uh
breakfast cereal
that's a good point when i eat sugar
smacks i can smell the sugar smacks
coming out
you guys notice that you have you have a
drink together
you
why did you ask him if he noticed your
pee smelling
do you two do everything are you like
timmy and tommy tibble you pee together
i thought it was a twin thing because he
come up to me say man
how did that like chicken uh the way
that uh kfc that spicy
oh it came out like fire yeah me too man
it's a twin thing
so i was just asking him yeah i think
everything happens to me happens to him
you have the connection like elliott and
e.t
where the warning feels bad the
sunflower dies yeah
it's a classic i don't know they're not
into sci-fi unless billy d williams is
in it
so uh conservative twins hodge twins so
we'll be talking also by the way i
should let you know
we called mashable yes right about the
remonetization yeah you know they made
some claims that we were selling these
shirts that we had never sold in our
lives they made some false claims so you
know what we called them to do
uh the journalism thing and uh
uh you'll be able to see it and uh
mashable hi hi hope all as well so
you'll be able to enjoy that call a
little bit later
good morning but first we have to get to
the dnc
the uh international rape federation
meeting
the international alleged rape
federation
meeting which is really weird because it
seems like you wouldn't have a
federation if it's alleged
yeah yeah like why make it official
official yeah it almost sounds like
you're claiming it
yeah we call that nothing i don't know i
wouldn't advise it but i'm not a
political adviser i'm not a karl rove
right donna brazile doesn't have me on
speed dial but don't call it rapist
federation allegedly
uh but this week and you guys talked
about this on youtube cardi b
interviewed joe biden so uh let's start
with that
i of course want free medicare we need a
free college education
you know what if i kill somebody i gotta
go to jail
i know exactly what it is but it used to
be it used to be derogatory term for
italian
yeah really yeah next thing i'm going to
call my button am i going to call my
boner at [ __ ]
was it is that guinea i thought it was
different
my nipples are guinea a different vowel
in the middle there
i don't know who knows i don't care this
is not a serious show um
so last night uh first off let's check
in with cnn because you guys you know
you wake up
later today yeah let's see what they're
doing trump's administration oh they're
talking about donald trump
really what's who and why is adam scott
a pundit
18 months later after this process he
was the mayor i think
barack obama looks to rally party and
young voters in speech tonight
oh well that needs 24-hour coverage the
democrats
are hoping for the youth vote oh well
the dumb vote yeah did you see barton's
face
it's like oh my god this is my base now
i'm disappointed i thought i was like
i thought i was a moderate no i think
that was just all the blood rushing to
his member
um so last night
the democratic national whatever
they uh i don't need to give them a
faith because they rape federation so
why do i need to give them
the pomp and circumstance um they
nominated an alleged sex offender joe
biden while of course providing a
marquee time slot to a not a legend
known uh sex offender apologist hillary
clinton
donald trump says the world well we are
the only major industrial economy
to have its unemployment rate tripled at
a time like this
the oval office should be a command
center instead it's a storm center
there's only chaos just one thing never
changes
you know his determination to deny
responsibility
and shift the blame the buck never stops
there
that knows just it's like he went to uh
to fantasy island do we have a picture
uh of lady elaine from mr rogers we can
pull it up that's what it looks like you
know it just it just keeps going that
knows of building
it says like the white house is supposed
to be a command center like when i uh
commanded that lady to you know you know
that whole thing you know
you remember the story when i commanded
her to
blow me drop down to your knees i need
the youth vote i understand you have to
be very straightforward
i realized i was doing more of a george
w i don't know what is my fault
oh my god he does look like that yeah
bring it back up oh
and you know what they also hang around
children's merry-go-rounds that's true
and i know oh allegedly bring up the
pictures of this guy with jeffrey
epstein's masseuse this just dropped
yesterday
okay bill clinton with hey by the way i
under she's cute
by the way
yeah what i am saying is there is
allegedly no foul play between those two
okay i want to be clear and he was just
saying hey can you crack my neck
but she was sexually abused look at go
back there that is lady go ahead look at
this picture yeah
i mean they have the same it's exactly
the same
it's just they're rosacea they're
disgusting
um and uh so we had pictures of this
lady who was sexually abused uh
by or claims to be sexually used by
jeffrey epstein do we have to say
allegedly with jeffrey epstein at this
point with all that half asian bill uh
for the dead guy
you're right rapist jeffrey epstein
got him a guy who had a i guess you
would call it a pagan altar
sauna i mean you see that guy shower the
guy had the sex
ranch yeah that's where he relaxes is
that uh pagan altar
you know what really bothered me most he
would get mad when the ladies would
steal the little shampoos
it's like you know what that's that's
your party favor
that's for the guests so bill clinton
claimed just to be clear we're talking
about joe biden hillary clinton you know
we know about joe uh we know about bill
clinton and juanita broderick we know
about bill clinton and monaco
we know about bill clinton a lot of
people now bill clinton said
uh as it related to jeffrey epstein that
he only flew in the lolita express the
rapist play the rape plane
um that's a new snoop dogg film rape
plane
uh it's a quality the lead express he
said four times okay well the call logs
and i don't know why i showed five four
and i went like
four this many all right hitting my
leather helmet
so um four times he flew at least 25 we
have the call logs okay now some people
say well that may not be a big deal he
also spent time on the uh the rapist
island
here's my question to you most americans
right if they don't work if you're not a
road warrior
most americans travel on average like a
handful of times per year
okay sure so the argument that they must
have slipped his mind the 25 or 27 times
depending on which call log you use
um to americans out there provided that
you don't work on the road you know we
up in the air need not apply to this can
you think of
any airline in the last few years that
you've flown on 26
times yeah but why would he want to
minimize his association with uh jeffrey
epstein she's trying to build up those
log hours
that would be like three free flights
with delta yeah or
think about american delta united
southwest or like vince vince young on
that's like vince when he bought every
single seat on southwest he didn't
realize he could have flown private
vince young scored less than statistical
random on the quarterback intelligence
test when he got the other job
yeah he was dumb he was a great athlete
but boy
no quarterback iq so think about
honestly to put it in context
do you think bill you travel quite a bit
half fashion bill yeah have you flown 26
times on any airline in the last few
years on one airline
i have but i have to travel a lot so do
you use the same airline all the time um
no
you don't use the same airline every
single time so a lot of the times i do
fly one airline because of the
proximity in that particular region but
you know when you when you look at the
road warrior
you know kind of question even if you're
on the road all the time i mean
you'd remember it look at it you'd have
to remember card right yeah
and you know what let's bring this up
you look a little bit like the alaska
airlines mascot
thank you that's why i thought you might
be flying alaska airlines
which you know land bridge theory the
inuit yes so
we're all asians let me know when you
get the alaska airlines
the little uh little stencil there so do
we have it
you type in alaska airlines mascot and
the first thing is just eskimo
they try to scrub it they cannot yeah
like you asked what a
the answer to a math problem is but it
just says
um google is racist i just want to say
all right
do we have we do have yeah okay let's
bring up alaska airlines really quickly
because that's who bill looks like
do we have it yeah all right we'll go
back to it yeah we'll go back to it so
uh a few weeks ago speaking of bill
clinton the alleged rapist uh court
documents they were unsealed where this
lady virginia however you call it in
english uh testified clinton was at
epstein's pedophile island with two
young girls
something that clinton always uh he's
denied right but it's like
you denied that you're in lolita express
yeah 26 times well i guess 26 minus four
22 times that's 22 denials i guess don't
forget the four
times he admitted it yes so 22 denials
and four
justice for justices
don't forget about monica yeah well i
don't know i don't think she made it on
the plane she was a little you know
she you don't need those old spinsters
yeah bringing up the
the median age there at pedophile island
what is this a nursing home
let's take bill clinton's word on this
one on the sexual assault
yeah i think that's that's probably the
best i mean that's what i'm saying it's
like if you take the word of
anyone there at the dnc it's like it's
like a mexican standoff of rape
it's like no i didn't do it how can you
prove it well bill clinton about me he's
like yeah well joe biden voucher me and
he's just like
where what is the thing
he just got two guns aimed at him he's
like this is what we're doing like no
joe just
okay aim good um and his is just a super
soaker it really is like who who vouches
for you there at the d
hillary clinton no joe biden no bill
clinton
no michelle obama who is effectively
recruiting for harvey weinstein if you
look at the speeches that she gave
no i don't know anything about uh i
don't know about gretchen whitmer but
you know i'm pretty sure
he's awkward just gotta die
went down on that island man if he's
getting sucked off in the oval
office could you imagine the stuff he
was doing down there yeah that's a good
i mean he's in the oval office
yeah the intern yeah we need to go
further
what do you think he's doing it when
it's a lady who's salaried
yeah like she was she was paid to
organize his envelopes those people were
paid to do whatever bill clinton wants
in the uh the pagan
uh shower sauna that's a good point god
knows what he was doing i mean i can
guess
i mean i wonder what he says he's yeah
no no let's not let's not wonder what he
said
yeah well you know what that was broad
enough that it was just slightly
revolting
the massage can we have the uh the
alaska airlines mascot
okay tell me this come on that's like
fast forward 30 years
that is the most racist thing i've ever
seen with the shading
and i don't know why they did that
that's a nice afternoon it looks groovy
man yeah
looks like an eskimo at a 70s roller
skater that's it i'm growing an afro
the look works okay
uh by the way hit the notification bell
uh if you haven't uh yet because
subscriptions don't mean a whole lot you
guys know that now right like
subscriptions don't really go in
people's subscription boxes so we got at
the notification bell we have this show
every weekday morning here at uh at 10
eastern i always want to say nine
because we're in central yeah and
tomorrow evening we are closing out the
dnc with 80's theme
night so tune in we're gonna have a
hashtag we have a party we have drinking
games
and we're going to be fact checking uh
joe biden kamala harris and
whoever else i don't think we have
anything prepped for tammy ducksworth
you know yeah we'll probably just cut to
the truth according to smooth manny at
that point we have some other stuff
because
it'll be fun gives a rat's ass on tammy
ducksworth i'm a senator
okay so uh
they defended bill clinton's inclusion
right at uh at the uh the convention
um and this was something i saw on cnn
which i just thought was so
telling uh they basically ended up
cutting the interview short where
someone was making a very valid point
kind of the point that half the country
would be thinking yeah
and i said well you know what i mean i
just think if you're saying hey
character matters look how terrible
donald trump is
and then very and then you're
introducing bill clinton like that's a
part of his open
that's a problem and they believe that
the bill clinton issue
has been settled just this is what they
do a lot right science on co
it's settled well what about the data on
black it's settled
what about the bill clinton the rape
it's settled what about the pictures
that came out today
nothingness why isn't the bill
thing settled i thought we all agreed
that he did it yeah that's the right
point
and that's also just code for shut up
yes it's a code
i don't like what you're saying young
man you keep that up you won't be in a
fourth quadrant for us anytime soon next
to adam scott this is cnn we take our
business very seriously stelter back to
you
rubbing balls so uh let's go to
allegedly uh let's go to this clip from
cnn so you can see how they have to
handle uh bill clinton when it arises
live
so you're going to say that in one
breath and then say character matters
ladies and gentlemen bill clinton i mean
does this make sense to anyone if you
want republicans to vote for joe biden
and talk about not having drama
this morning this has already been asked
and answered
decades ago no it's a horrible person
it's a goal decades ago not everyone
talks in michigan that way just
just the [ __ ] governors oh i don't
know what it is like you walk around
they have a little bit you know they
might say roof instead of roof but then
you have a governor whitmer and her or
the former michigan governor
well you know back in michigan that's a
matter of fact what are you just are you
getting
dialect lessons from michael moore
playing playing to that rural base right
now who by the way i'm not convinced is
not in transition right now michael
moore have you seen him
oh my god he looks like rosie o'donnell
yeah i know hey
don't insult rosie looks like
walter white on testosterone blockers um
jesus christ
so this is they say it settled decades
ago well it really wasn't settled
decades ago
we have new pictures and i would think
it's relevant considering that if you
watch the epson files on netflix right
they keep these
they show that picture with donald trump
like three four or five times
donald trump didn't travel on the lead
express he's not in the call log donald
trump did host jeffrey epstein in
mar-a-lago and then kicked him out
because he thought he was creepy
yeah very quickly good reason it's a
pretty good reason in other words the
story
rather than just a picture of donald
trump at a party right i'm sure you
could find a picture of donald trump at
a party with all kinds of unsavory
characters you know probably you have
jeffrey epstein bill clinton elena
dunham they all show up at these met
galas
the point is that's not the same as
traveling on his plane and going to his
sex island repeatedly and denying it
donald trump booted epstein from
mar-a-lago
that guy that guy this [ __ ] thing i
don't like
namely that he does kids that's what i
think donald trump said
not a good guy and how does bill clinton
not get me too when aziz ansari has a
bad date
yeah yeah i don't like it is politics at
all that's a bad date when you look at
how how does he
not get me to when at the very least at
the very least
what we know what he denied under oath
and then admitted to
abusing his power as the president of
the united states on
an intern even if she was willing right
this idea regretful p and v is what's
taught is rape
well what about the president of the
united states
exerting his power over you to get a bj
underneath the uh the
the white house desk yeah and that's
just what we know about all this other
we also know he just dropped his pants
and walked up to i mean you can you can
search
jennifer flowers you can search money to
product we know that he made
uncomfortable advances
and we know that he had extramarital
affairs with people who worked for him
and we know that he denied it under oath
we know all those things
we just don't know uh we just don't know
what the bed post notches would read
in regards to a pedophile you think he'd
be target number one for me too
it's strange that he's not just you
thinking number one
i don't know people for example they
give him a wide burst because that
bayonet on his nose hey he's got a black
kid too
yeah he's got a black kid bill clinton
yeah he did it
just like him but he's light-skinned oh
oh yeah i know what you're talking about
yeah well
all allegedly no oh it's the legs you
know
you can switch it up and just say
purported reported purported
yeah purported john has been reported
he's got a black son
others have said yeah i hear people say
yeah and here's something when people do
they say it's settled well bill clinton
has refused to apologize for anything
i think we have this link up here from
uh from cnn nbc nbc nbc msnbc
so many nbc's and all of them are
useless
can i fact-check you real quick yeah
yeah bill clinton has apologized for
that but he did apologize for the racist
policies that he put into place
that set back black communities for
decades that he put into place when he
was president
he did just a couple years ago he came
out and he admitted that he screwed over
the black community for
decades because of the policies he put
into place you know what that makes me
respect him less but i thought he was
the first black president
at least just double down it's like if
you're if you're a racist bill clinton
by god be the best racist you can be
stick to your goods he also apologized
remember because he used to really like
fast food and then he became a vegan
oh yeah i didn't know he's really vegan
that's what he weighs on you at night
i wondered why he was willowing away no
one he looks horrible
that's what weighs on you it's like ah
not the sexual assault not the abusive
power not the alleged purported rape but
burger king yeah you got it yeah i'm a
cholesterol
whopper junior she's going oh good oh
you know how somebody's going to order
the chicken fries yeah
one tour you know you win so you're like
oh i said what and i do this a lot i'm
like oh i can't believe i did that
going to sleep and my wife goes what
what's wrong because i don't i realize
that i go like this
audibly if bill clinton is doing that
with a junior bacon cheeseburger
not the rape victim maybe it's just a
code name you know what
different strokes chicken fries they
wanted it yeah
some people count she won when i'm
worried i can't sleep
i count my rape victims instead of sheep
and you'll fall asleep hearing their
screams
hey what does my life become
there will be a lot of tonight
i'll be haunted by the ghost of bing
crosby just show up with his golf swing
hey stephen what the f all right so this
we obviously see the coverage but it
does bother me when you see people who
just say oh the media is by so
this is a new segment we're going to be
introducing i wanted to actually uh go
to another story where you see the
difference in coverage not just bill
clinton and the
rapist convention known as the uh the
the dnc um but something just
recently happened with a man being
beaten within his inch within an inch of
his life was this in uh
i i keep losing truck was in portland
we'll get to in a second but we're going
to compare it with another story that
everybody remembers in a new segment we
call
then and now
all right so that's my local band by the
way is it a local band check them out it
seems like a local cover band
this is the kind of band that like would
show up and do their covers and then
mega death would say you can't use your
skeleton guys
let's get on right off the stage no
that's that's uh iron maiden
oh iron maiden that's right iron man
what's the name of the skeleton guy in
iron man i don't know skeletor
something like that skeletor i don't
know
i'm not saying i don't like iron maiden
to people out there because i know they
have
you know i'm just saying if your music
requires a gimmick
um you know something with grateful dead
they do the same skeleton little guy
mr saturday night okay what's that
what's the great dead song
uncle tom's band look at tom's band
just dropping n-bombs
wow that's me by the way i was i'll let
me
i want to continue this with ben and now
but i was just talking about this you
know joe lewis which by the way is
really surprising because you guys used
to be afraid of dogs and your pet and
joe lewis
um the correction word for joe lewis is
no
right so like saying if you hear if i
say i'm going to take him for a walk i
have to say w because he recognizes the
word
and when he doesn't you don't like you
say no so you correct him but i realized
that the uninitiated
people who hear me and my wife talking
to the dog
will say hey no if he if he doesn't
listen say the n word
so someone here say the n word to the
dog named joe lewis
in context my favorite boxer ever and it
came with some scar tissue looked a
little bit like jules says you know
that's a good name for a dog joe lewis
and we're saying n word meaning
no but that is something that definitely
could be you know a cancelable offense
we know it's not rape
oh of course yeah it was a callback that
was you guys
you guys need more black rifle coffee by
the
way
uh entering your blackriflecoffee.com
code credit i think you get 20 off
and uh they are really doing well right
now black rifle get it we're waiting on
some of this this is a prop coffee
man this is prop this has been around
you i don't even know how i filled that
full of beans
join the coffee club listen that it's
telling me
it needs it needs a friend send it come
on
sorry it's damn um remember sandman the
covington kids who by the way i think
just got 80 million from cnn is that
something was that reported something
like that someone had wronged
that it's supposed to be confidential
but oh okay yeah
who knows they have sources well just
the one kid or did all the kids
get that split up oh i know if that's
the case that's gonna be like lord of
the flies
yeah just they're gonna be fighting each
other like chronicles
yeah go at it um he's the highest paid
journalist at cnn
it did have to write now one article
watch next thing you know brian seltzer
is going to try and sleep
with him for a prime time slot
so let's remember uh
what the media reaction was immediately
following
the covington kids this matters at least
some of the students were from covington
catholic high school in kentucky
the catholic diocese of covington which
oversees the schools you guys get a real
kick out of it
what's going on catholic school students
towards nathan phillips specifically
and native americans in general we
extend our deepest apologies to mr
phillips
this behavior is opposed to the church's
teachings on the dignity
and respect of the human being the
diocese also said the matter is under
investigation
and that some students could be expelled
wouldn't understand anymore
dignity and respect how it's tough to
have dignity respect for a guy who's a
serial liar and has no gum line
yeah he's losing all his teeth what do
you expect them to do
it's been what two years i still don't
understand how this story just yeah took
off definitely
it was a white kid who smiled ah yes
his greatest sin was having a punchable
face let's give the left that he had a
little bit of a face where you just
gotta give it to him child you know yeah
i'm just saying what i'm saying like i
have that face i get
i have a face that has a lot of punch
appeal right you just wanna you know
paint a target yeah they're gonna get it
that kid got all that chin action
yeah it's all man i just wanna punch
that kid in the face all right well that
could be taken out of context
we congratulate your win nick sandman
hey yeah good for you
and by the way not all black people okay
they're that not all right and these
they don't all want to punch you in the
face what's wrong with you
i love them nick salmon big fan here
buddy
big fan it's your life
oh right let's compare that to uh
uh what happened was this yesterday or
two days ago several days ago uh i think
it was two days ago now where black
lives matter they tried to rob someone
in portland
um then a man and his partner they
defended the victim i want to make sure
i get this right so people don't get
upset with me
then black lives matter chased them they
got into their truck the mob tried to
chase them down to their truck and then
the driver crashed the truck
and then there was a black lives matter
activist and this is why by the way i
think a lot of
conservatives are cowardly out there
where they say antifa like listen that's
why we switch the sign from ant for the
black lives matter because
they're one in the same as far as
tactics but people are afraid of calling
out black lives matter for fear of being
called racist
i'm not saying black people black lives
matter the organization and people who
subscribe to that philosophy
that world view i believe that they are
uh
part of or supporting a domestic terror
organization by definition because
of the violence that is often encouraged
and used and at the very least
not actively condemned in these cities
across country sometimes
but not at the heads of the organization
and that is a problem that i have so
let's compare that to
a black lives matter activist i'm
warning you this is graphic okay so not
a trigger warning an
actual warning if you have kids around
this is what happened
in portland this week
by the way the irony in calling him the
n-word and then calling him a racist
don't get any dumber than that
get him out of the seat get him out of
the [ __ ]
so again now to be clear white kid
smiling
covington was covered from from start
everywhere
right right that's all you saw everyone
remembers that and they were totally
wrong they have egg on their face and so
of course they never really issued the
full correction retraction except well i
guess you could consider
80 million one hell of an addendum um
no one covered it yesterday we've been
trying to search so we'll show you some
overlays from when we were searching for
this yesterday washington post did run a
headline
man seriously injured an attack after
crashing his tuck
uh truck during black lives matter
protest in portland well
seems a little a little vague it seems a
little bit vague how about
the man was beaten within an inch of his
life when you consider that national
made-up stories or the verge uh
regarding us that didn't even basically
stories with quotes that we never made
and uh stories that never even actually
happened from places that we've never
been
you would think that they could get this
right like how about including a quote
where he said
yeah take it racist and then immediately
called him the n-word that's a quote
that i think would interest people
because they'd be going wait what does
that say he kicked the guy who said the
n-word
he said he was the reason he said the
n-word and so confused did bill clinton
rape anybody i don't know how to read a
newspaper it's been settled steven he
did
it's been settled settled it's been
answered minutes ago
and the way the headline reads it's not
really clear if he was one of the
demonstrators or if yeah
like the demonstrators were the ones who
were committing the violent acts yeah of
course it's not clear in the headline of
course
no of course it's not clear he's wearing
a shirt with security on it too right
i i don't know this is that transformer
oh i think it was a transformer shirt
yeah he knows he's a nerd
so let's go back to then with the
sandman story the covington kids uh when
the truth did come out with the full
footage
again this is important because what
matters is not only when they get a
story wrong but what do they do to
correct it and we'll be
showing that call to mashable we made
yesterday in a little bit so i hope you
enjoy that
instead of admitting they were wrong
they tried to turn it into a hole he
said
she said right it was nothing more than
conjecture and they were airing after
this more interviews
with um noted uh uh ambassador for
methamphetamine
nathan phillips so not forgive him
that he didn't think he owed an apology
but he does wish that he had walked away
was that enough for you or do you think
he should have apologized
well if there's an apology there'd be an
apology
for his own behavior to
a lot of other people's beside me i'd be
like way down on the list of his people
he needs to apologize to
you could just end the phrase that i'd
be way down the list and we could apply
it to anything
way down the list of people to apologize
to
um uh people whose picture would be up
for dental records
people to watch your children yeah
way way down short of being a mule
through an airport you'd be right at the
top
everywhere else you're at least bottom
uh
you know 94th percentile and even mule
they'd probably pass them up because he
kind of looks like a musician yeah you
know that's true
right away
look just like uh what's that uh shrek
the donkey yeah
yeah yeah um
and here's just to be clear people who
haven't followed up on the story those
kids did nothing it was black hebrew
israelites who were a cost of them who
basically said that white people cannot
go to hell
all white people are going to hell i had
to deal with these people when i was in
michigan by the way
um and then uh the kids did then nathan
phillips came up
living off the land while he made sure
that someone taped his iphone hey
do you have it in portrait mode
no galaxies it doesn't have the 12
megapixel camera
yeah yeah the white man makes me live
like this
today's show here i come you levi's
wearing
fake first nations prick so
um washington post after they knew all
this they went with a story well it's
more complicated that was their headline
more complicated than we initially
thought
which really means like we screwed up
you trusted us usa today covington
catholic videos show life is complicated
but we still saw what we saw no
no no no no no no no
but did you see what led up to it did
you see that they were basically saying
all white people go to hell when you
look at black hebrew israelites and you
look into their theology
much like black lives matter the
organization this is a black supremacist
organization it's entirely predicated on
the idea that jesus was black
therefore white people is the devil
um the table switches still a leap yeah
which is still kind of a leap
yeah i don't think i've ever met anyone
who cares about jesus's race more than
black hebrew israelites i mean
it's predicated it's like i don't think
white people care like people like well
you think white jesus was white with
blue eyes like
nah that was the thing that the church
did because it looked good on stained
glass we know he probably looked like a
terrorist
what did he just most likely look like
he looks like sodom hussein
yeah i'm just saying if jesus were alive
today yelling at a fig tree
i'd probably pat him down make him take
his shoes off
jesus check them yeah yeah that says
more about you
that says more about me and that's the
wonder of christ
it is yes she's holding up a mirror to
myself
but that's the whole thing is that you
are you were non-descript visually
that's what the bible says like you
wouldn't have noticed him he didn't have
an incredible presence yeah
but then black hebrew israelites like no
that's some [ __ ]
he was black and the story white people
cannot go to heaven it says so
revelation
white horse i can't read
i love your black men boys had that when
i was in i was in grand rapids michigan
there's a sign right there people know
it was on the corner of a place called
hop cat
and these black cube razor lights were
always out there yeah and they have this
sign it has a picture of a
just you know it kind of looks like the
alaska airlines thing because it looks
like an afro they have a sign
that you know looks like a black
gentleman with a at this point it was
kana was
kind of not quite house party not quite
afro but it was it was a little higher
on the top than the signs i don't know
what you call that just like the
microphone
no no jefferson look i'm describing
christ so it says the lord
says on the sign it says jesus
uh like with an arrow pointing like it's
a turn off jesus yeah
yeah yeah they go hey they go hey have
you made peace with your lord and
have you made pete do you know what's
going to happen if you die today that's
what they said to me and i'm like
why would they care and i was like oh
okay um i said well i know you're a
christian they go yes sir i said okay
actually they didn't say sir they
probably said like yes [ __ ] they were
not very quiet
yes edomite and i can't remember this
isn't all word for word
but uh i said well yeah you know listen
as a christian i've personally accepted
jesus christ my lord and savior i
believe he is who he said he is he's god
in the flesh and that the only way to
heaven is through him they go now
are you are you aware that the only true
god's people
are black hebrew israelites and they
were going i was like
okay sure yeah i don't care like i don't
know i don't know what all of them look
like no
if that's the case i don't want to go to
heaven i would go to hell with you
it's safer there
i take my chances with you white
supremacy
i ain't going we're touching dying and
going to heaven you see the black
israelites there
i say hell no i'm going to hell but i'm
going to
white people uh well effectively at the
end of the day they basically told me uh
you can't go to heaven
and you white people are so obsessed
with the color jesus skin do you think
jesus was a white man i said
you know what i don't care let's say he
looks like you're uh like your roller
rink guy there on your poster
i'm fine i can still follow jesus right
they go no
why did you waste my time wait hold on a
second how do i get to heaven you're
like well that's for you to find out
why don't you tell me today let me ask
you this i finally do but in your
opinion
is there any way for me to get to heaven
they're like that's up in the air
i'm like okay all right you know what
i'm pretty sure that you aren't reading
the same book i like how they're
lawyering it right they're like keeping
their options open like yeah
well we this didn't go the way we
thought it was gonna go because he seems
very accepting about a jesus that
doesn't look like a white guy
and now uh did it look anything like
this right here the uh black jesus yeah
okay yeah that guy looks pretty cool
at least they uh didn't make you kiss
their feet
oh i don't know did you see those videos
it's funny too whatever you see them
reading verses out of the bible and then
they interpret what it means i'm like
that's totally not what it means
right yeah exactly now kiss my feet
get down there you evil white man i
don't know
are you mary magdalene or not i guess
not
he said he's not
wait a minute now what it's like one of
those goosebumps choose your own path
only it ends with racism no matter what
every time and why can't we these are
black supremacists black hebrew
israelites that is a black supremacy
group yeah same thing with black lives
matter when you say when nick cannon
says that white people have
no soul or don't have soul meaning the
ability i guess to sing dance i don't
know because of melanin
that is actual racism and i want to be
clear i don't think
that joe biden is a racist i don't think
that donald trump is a racist because
people on the right they're trying to
say joe biden is a racist they're trying
to paint both sides
listen i don't think that any of them
actually harbor ill will toward black
people i don't think that they believe
that they are inferior i think that joe
biden the dnc panders a whole lot more
but there are actual racists out there
of course
for the few remaining you can count on
one hand clans members and spikely will
make a film about them yes
actual racists and so are people who say
that jesus was black
exclusively and white people have no
path to heaven that is racism but
call me old-fashioned so back to black
lives matter portland they actually they
id the suspect okay
marquise love what's the name it
sounds like a reality show host find a
shot at
love only kicks you in the head yeah i
was looking for a date
oh i thought it was curb stomp show on
vh1 so
the cursed love that's the follow-up
show
he's still on the loose this is why this
matter we're talking about the job of
reporters right seeing they're like oh
we take journalism very seriously brian
stelter and we get it you want a [ __ ]
about trump i understand you don't like
him and you have your pennies in a bunch
right now the guy who just beat someone
within an inch of their life
and you know his motivation right you
know the motivation black lives matter
the domestic terrorist organization
there's no guesswork here as to why he
did it you're saying you racist calling
him the n word i can't say it you guys
can say it
that's the rules you can say it if it's
a white guy who's bleeding out
i guess i don't understand the rules
here and i don't understand why the
media doesn't feel that it's a
responsibility we used to have america's
most wanted get
john walsh's white ass on it for crying
out loud this
the whole point is if if the media
cannot be used
to uh protect more innocent lives from
being harmed by a violent criminal
on the loose right now what purpose do
you serve
right the whole point is the news that's
fit to print the news that people should
know
the news that can impact people's lives
well this is someone who
beat the crap out of somebody who's in
the icu as far as we know right now
has been id'd not by you of course in
the media and you could save you could
protect
other american lives black and white
alike
why doesn't that fall under the
responsibility under the purview
of the media's responsibility if he's
white to be a man i mean it'd be all
over the news
it feels black yeah well if he was white
and he was kicking a black guy yeah
yeah yeah yeah they just don't care they
just honestly don't care
i think we have it we have it here uh
cnn msnbc if we brought that up because
we ran some searches to try and
you don't see it you don't find this
being written about and you certainly
don't find it being written about
accurately there you go we searched
msnbc and we searched cnn and it wasn't
there there's apparently some lady
marilyn manson with some kind of a
turquoise jewelry i have no idea
apparently it's more important than
finding out oh my gosh there's someone
loosing my toners kicking people's
esses in the street telling us oh wait
wait fat oprah crying on a treadmill
mm-hmm
let me click this stars who are dead
wayne hold on a second corey phillman's
still alive
you got me with your slideshow um so
the media the media the legitimate media
or as youtube calls them
authoritative sources exactly and as
mashable calls them authoritative
sources
which okay so that leads us into the
next uh segment here uh it is going to
be time to tell
youtube we are really quickly going to
go to the mashable call that we made
yesterday because there's a lot of
referencing authoritative sources that
also reference authoritative sources and
there's no actual original source but
for right now
piss off youtube